مشاهدينا في اخر التطورات على الارض لابد
ان نبدا بسولدار ومخبط بملف سوليدار
وبخموت هناك روايتين متناقدتين بين كل من
فاجنر بهذه المنطقه التي تدور فيها
المعارك منذ اوائل الاسبوع فاقدر تقول
بانها حكمت السيطره على سوليدار بينما
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لم توضع هذا الامر
وايضا اكياف نفته نفيا قاطعا وهذا ما
سيشرحه الزميل رائد الاخضر لاحقا بالنقل
المباشر طبعا سوليدار اليوم ما زالت هناك
معارك فيها
وتحديدا في الجبهه الغربيه حيث استخدمت
اكياس بعض التعزيزات الى هذه الجبهه
تحديدا في سوليد اما باخ موت بما ان
السيطره لم تحتم على سوليدار وبالتالي هذه
المنطقه همم التي اذا ما سقطت سوليدار
يمكن للقوات الروسيه احكام السيطره عليها
وطبعا همم تطويقه من كل الجبهات ما لها
باحكام السيطره عليها ولكن حتى الساعه
يمكن القول بان باخموت ما زالت خارج
السيطره الروسيه بالملف ايضا الاخر على
الارض مدينه دونياسك بالساعات الاخيره
هناك قصف اوكراني كثيف
لدونيس طبعا البعض وصفوا بالقصف انتقامي
لما يحصل بالمناطق الاخرى وتحديدا في
سوليدار حيث قصفت الدفاع الاوكرانيه 90
صاروخا بالاربعه والعشرين الماضيه مما ادى
الى مقتل شخص واصابه اثنين اخرين بجروح
وطبعا قصف البنيه التحتيه
والمرافق السكنيه بهذه المنطقه اذا كانت
هذه اخر التطورات على الارض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]